-The midterm elections
are coming up,
and with many citizens
still scarred
and needing emotional support
after 2020,
we turn to one of our writers,
Jeff Wright, to help voters out.
Let's take a look.
-Alrighty, welcome
to the voter support group.
As we all know,
midterms are here,
and this can be a really
stressful time for voters.
So today we'll open up the floor
for you to express
your frustrations with voting.
Who wants to go first?
-I'll go first.
[ Clears throat ]
If you couldn't tell
by my jeans and plaid shirt,
I'm a Republican.
-[ Booing ]
-Come on, now.
-Like I was saying,
I'm a Republican,
and being a Republican is hard.
Everyone automatically assumes
I'm a Trump supporter.
-Did you vote for Trump?
-I did.
-Come on, man.
-But not because
I agree with him.
-You don't?
-No.
Voting is like having
a favorite football team.
You got to stick with your team,
even if your quarterback
is under multiple
criminal investigations.
-Who's your favorite
football team?
-The Browns.
-[ Booing ]
-Yeah, I know.
You can boo. It's fair.
-Let's move on.
Who wants to go next?
-I'll go.
I'm an old voter.
And I don't like
that everyone can vote.
It's too easy now,
and I hate it.
Back in my day,
you had to work hard to vote,
and that vote meant something.
-Here we go again.
-It was a mission
to get your vote in.
You had to wake up before
the sun, look for your shoes,
then realize you're
already wearing them.
Oh, then I'd walk seven miles
through the snowstorm
with the summer sun
beaming on my back.
It was hot.
-Snowstorm in the summer?
-And don't forget the goblin
waiting in front of the booth.
You had to say, "Swiper,
no swiping, Swiper, no swiping."
And he still might not
let you in.
-Alright, that's all the time
you have left.
-Well, I vote I keep going.
-I bet you do.
Who wants to go next?
-I'll go.
Hi, everyone.
I'm a Democrat, which means
I love black people.
Just not in my neighborhood.
-Hey, I'm with you on that.
-I'm tired of people thinking
just because I'm a Democrat,
I would never vote
for a Republican.
Maybe I like what Republicans
have to offer.
-Oh, what do you like
that the Republicans offer?
-Well, they offer
a lot of, um...
If you think about it,
they, uh, uh...
I mean, Tom Brady once said --
Wait, is Tom Brady a Republican
or is he just rich?
-And handsome.
Rich and handsome.
-Alright, l-let's move on.
How about you next, young voter?
-I'm a young voter,
which means I don't vote.
-[ Booing ]
-Come on, now.
-Hey, I thought you said
no judgment.
-Mnh-mnh, that deserved a boo.
-Alright, sorry about that.
Continue.
-I just don't know
why they make it so hard.
I got to stand in line
in my old high school gym
and use a pen like an old person
on a Tuesday.
I work on Tuesdays.
-You do?
-I mean, I could.
I could work on Tuesdays.
-Come on, man.
-And besides,
even after an election
these days,
some people still
don't accept the results.
-Like who?
-Like him.
-Hey.
-Care to chime in?
-Oh, no, I have plenty to say --
after the election.
-[ Clears throat ]
I just want to say,
when it comes to
political parties,
there are bad people
on both sides.
-[ Booing ]
-Shut up.
-Th-There are good people
on both sides, too.
-[ Booing ]
-Shut up.
-Okay. I guess
I'll just keep sweeping.
-And I'll borrow this.
-Maybe as a young voter
I'd be more inclined to vote
if you could do it online.
-See, that's y'all problem.
Y'all young kids
want everything online.
You want to vote online.
You want your food online.
You want your girlfriend online.
Shoot, you want Netflix online.
-Netflix is online.
-Not mine.
My Netflix is on my TV.
-'Cause your TV's online.
-Mnh-mnh, not me.
I get my Netflix
in a little envelope.
Then I open it up,
then I blow on it,
make sure it's still good.
Then I put it inside
what's called a DVD player.
Y'all young kids
don't know nothing about that.
-'Cause we just watch it
on our phones.
-Your phone?
Your phone's a DVD player?
This is tricky.
Hold on. Siri!
-Alright, is there anyone else
that hasn't spoken?
-Hi. My name is Jeff,
and I'm an alcoholic.
Actually, I think
I'm in the wrong room.
-Oh, no,
you're in the right room.
-Siri!